hello ladies and gentlemen I am Ryan
Wright and I'm Breanna white Breanna and
I today are gonna check out the video
from all-time movies
top 10 most paused movie moments let's
see what they are did someone just show
Ryan outside you know I heard something
we've got to get murdered
see now I'm really paranoid many murder
jokes I live in a dangerous neighborhood
man hey guys I'm Chris and today I'm
going to be looking at the most paused
moments in film history yep those
moments which got us reaching for the
remote control wearing out our VHS tapes
and asking ourselves if we really just
saw what we just saw so get ready for
easter eggs in jokes and yeah pheromones
beauty so let's go number 10 psycho
after 100 minutes of horrifying hotels
shower slash Essenes clothed corpses
Hitchcock had one more surprise in store
for us in the final scenes of the 1960
movie psycho if you look carefully as
the camera zooms in on crazed murderer
Norman Bates you'll see Hitchcock
overlaid a picture of Nora Bates a skull
onto the smiling face of the
psychopathic hostel owner Oh in case it
wasn't freaky enough number 9 Star Wars
Episode 4 perhaps one of the most famous
bloopers in film history is the
accident-prone storm trooper who banks
is here breaking into the control room
no his clumsiness on the lack of
concentration duty to food I did not
know
for the first in a tech of the clothes
George Lucas planted an O March to the
accident-prone guard by having Jango
Fett bumped his head on a low doorway
number eight Trading Places dan Aykroyd
wasn't the only one stunned by Jamie Lee
Curtis when she went topless in the 1983
film despite appearing in two entries of
the nudity happy horror franchise
Halloween when Trading Places was
released
Jamie had still retained her modesty on
camera anyway flashing the flesh in this
oscar-winning comedy certainly silenced
some of the rumour mongers claiming she
was a hermaphrodite she does look good
it's poured a million stretched VHS
copies Jamie Lee Curtis all-time movies
salute she knows I'm gay movies number
seven Iron Man but eagle-eyed Marvel
fans were on the ward animation of
Captain America shield in the background
of Iron Man in a clear nod to the
extended Marvel Universe beyond the
movie director Jon Favreau explained the
shield began as a crude joke before
being left in to see if anyone would
spot it let's face it this is not the
worst thing you've got me doing two
years later the shield reappeared and
got an upgrade from Easter Egg to plot
points but by this time we had already
seen the cap in action in his own movie
never mind that the shield's don't match
number six Lion King chorus Disney seems
a lot less innocent when it appeared
that the word six is spelt out in the
dustcloud resist 94 classic now Disney
has firmly stated that that dustcloud
actually spelled out is FX a sneaky
message from the special effects crew
but I'll let you decide about
number five cabin in the woods it is no
surprise that if you spend your days
watching people get picked off by the
scariest monsters in history you might
need to find something too maybe it just
lighten up the mood of it so we can
forgive the group masterminding the
cabin in the woods for placing bets on
which horrific monster was going to pop
up next but the list of monsters is
definitely worth taking a closer look at
among them are sexy witches the Sugar
Plum Fairy and of course they're all
classic dismemberment goblins
angry molesting the tree really exactly
once the cabin is it's a reference to
Elijah woods creepy Sin City cannibal
interesting number four Basic Instinct
it cannot be a surprise that this one
has made the list the vision is blink
enormous at moments in cinema history
has to be Sharon Stone and her infamous
leg cross with a shot straight up her
dress teenage boys everywhere wore out
their VHS tapes trying to find the exact
moment that she uh bears it all no one
was more surprised at the scene then
actually Sharon herself during the
filming the director asked her to remove
her underwear claiming it interfere with
the lights but he had a shirt home
nothing would be seen when she saw the
final scene and surprisingly she slapped
him hard across the face
number three I did not know the night's
mark walberg join the crime on end of
this porn epic after two and a half
hours of teasing us with weave - on his
dude though unlike Sharon Stone
he wasn't flashing his actual private
palm and instead he wore prosthetic
penis and Merkin sculpted around
Wahlberg's own penis the original
meanwhile inches long but the crew
decided to shorten it claiming the
larger model looked like a weird monster
penis Wahlberg wore the fake penis even
when not on screen he claims it is the
only property has ever taken home from a
set although after nearly 10 years it's
probably gotten a little bit rotten
number two Fight Club
pause David Fincher's movie at the exact
right frame and you'll be rewarded with
bread per year
flashing up behind a doctor in hospital
swell before we are even introduced to
the character
he also crops up in a TV commercial in
an office and during a meeting for men
with cancer oh yeah and one more thing
to look out for Tyler describes getting
a kick out of sneaking scenes from
pornos in two films with family
audiences so obviously Fincher decided
to do the exact same thing to us and
inserted a penis into the film's final
phrase would it dick
number one Who Framed Roger Rabbit
really want another female character you
forgot to put on her underwear when the
police came calling right after this car
crash glamorous cartoon pinup Jessica
Rabbit goes commando not that commando
this commando really she might just be a
cartoon but she can be credited with
sparking the sexual awakening of young
boys everywhere oh jeez no so
well guys that was my list what's your
most paused movie moment tell me in the
comments below don't forget to Like and
subscribe and we'll see you next time
and hey if you like this video check out
the top 10 trailers better than the
actual movie in it
Wow okay okay there are pretty
interesting are some interesting moments
in there uh psycho I did not know that I
didn't know that either that's a pretty
creepy moment [ __ ] Hitchcock man
amazing things that Hitchcock does
cheese I have a Hitchcock yeah yeah I
thought this joke we go further than I
realized it's a relationship and then
yeah it's like well I just gave away the
punchline Hitchcock points for trying
though you know the guy and Star Wars
who bumped his head so I had never seen
that I'm surprised I never noticed that
or haven't told that I think that makes
movies a little bit better when you're
like I wonder who that guy is
I know like who is that he's famous if I
got fired for doing that I'm surprised
me they didn't even notice that anyone
had done it again hopefully you know
that that guy was there like I hope no
one noticed George Lucas might have been
baked out of his mind had uh you know
the guy hit his head and thought it was
really funny could I mean we thought it
was hilarious it was hilarious there's a
reason I think it's hilarious because
George and I have something in common
Trading Places I didn't think you have
paused like a scene where like the
moments that are like really paused in
this list it's like oh you got a really
catchy yeah you do
like I talked about in another video in
wild wild west
you can catch Will Smith's balls if you
play it and really slow-motion applause
available ready yeah
and same thing with Keanu Reeves in the
matrix you can catch his balls
Dow's those are the kind of moments I
wanted but to see Trading Places on here
with Jamie Lee Curtis his tits she does
have really nice tits and I'm with me
like her tits are we really urge I don't
know her besides like Freaky Friday like
I I mean I will always associate her
with the movie Freaky Friday well she's
so I don't like it it kind of surprised
me news
I know I just for some reason that's the
one that sticks for me she we seen her
lies oh oh gosh she's so sexy that movie
has a sexy dance Jimmy good for hours
gosh I love for Jamie Lee Curtis to me
my Alfred Hitchcock the Iron Man ones
obvious I've heard this I've heard the
sex one from The Lion King before but I
never really bought it I never did
either for the life of me I can't see it
no matter how hard I try and for it
scene SFX like I could totally buy that
yeah the real shocking went to me was
the Basic Instinct moment it was really
popular when she flashes her badge yeah
I had no idea Sharon Stone didn't know
that that was gonna be that is one of
the most fucked-up things I have ever
heard cuz I would believe it oh it's
missing it the lighting what the thing
is you put so much trust in a director
yeah it's so messed up oh my god I feel
so bad for Sharon Stone I know I know I
know
I wonder if she sued or something she
totally could have could she huh well I
bet it wasn't in the contract you should
Sharleen Shia full frontal nudity and
tits baring are totally different
categories trustful really I don't know
I'd be I'd be furious and Boogie Nights
with Mark Wahlberg's dick at the end
okay yeah I know it's a prosthetic that
really bums me out I would have wanted
to see more of all bruised real penis I
know and I love seeing celebrity photos
when they're naked like when they catch
them naked like sting and Brad Pitt well
it's like seeing a different side of
them sure you mean like emotionally
there's something about them where
you're like I just want you know it's
always the thing that's they bear
everything about them in this in a movie
but you don't see Brad Pitt's penis in a
movie
let's see Brad Pitt's penis Mark
Wahlberg I wish he showed his actual
[ __ ] they said its sculpted it after the
real one that's the thing is like is it
really that different people are seeing
it regardless like what what is so
sacred about it that you have to hide it
no wonder Mark Wahlberg is so confident
he has such a huge wing and dealing yeah
I just really want to see Mark
Wahlberg's penis just once and for all
but anyway guys thanks for tuning in to
the channel if you're new to it you can
subscribe to the real rejects you can
check out Brianna
White's Facebook page modeling photos on
there check it out boys and she also has
a YouTube channel gaming related it's
gonna be starting up soon check it out
right now that way you'll get notified
when videos are up and you can follow us
on Facebook Instagram Twitter vine and
periscope God if I had a bigger penis I
would be so confident do you think
that's the secret to Mark Wahlberg's
confidence yeah really everyone I know
we're the big penis has a lot of
confidence you think isn't really about
the penis though come on Alyssa come in
come in come in me come in me come in me